bonjour à tous ravi de vous retrouver
sur Public Sénat à suivre ce matin un
débat portant sur le cice le Crédit
Impôt compétitivité emploi un débat qui
s'est tenu mardi au Sénat à la demande
du groupe communiste les parlementaires
ont ainsi pu faire le bilan de cette
mesure qui est entrée en vigueur au mois
de janvier 2013 alors le cice avait été
mise en place à la suite des
préconisations du rapport du fameux
rapport de l'ugalois sur la
compétitivité des entreprises un rapport
qui estimait que le coût du travail est
trop élevé en France alors quasiment 2
ans plus tard où en est-on et bien il
est vrai que le CCE tarde à porter ses
fruits dernièrement la très critique
Martine auri a estimé que le cice
n'était qu'un saupoudrage qu'il ne
visait pas suffisamment les entreprises
qui en ont réellement besoin et plus
globalement il est vrai que le cice n'a
pas été utilisé autant qu'il aurait pu
l'être par les entreprise en effet de
nombreuses entreprises sont trop
découragées par la complexité des
procédures à suivre tout de suite donc
retour à ce débat qui s'est tenu à la
demande du groupe communiste mardi au
Sénat l'ordre du jour appelle le débat
sur le bilan du crédit d'impôt
compétitivité emploi qui est une demande
du groupe CRC
la la parole est tout d'abord à
l'orateur du groupe qui a demandé ce
débat madame Marie-France beaufil pour
le groupe communiste républicain et
citoyens vous avez la parole ma cher
collègue madame la présidente madame la
ministre mes chers collègues le crédit
d'impôt compétitivité emploi est entrée
en vigueur le 1er janvier 2013 faisant
suite au rapport Galois sur la situation
de notre
industrie l'objectif de la mesure visait
à restaurer la compétitivité de nos de
nos entreprises contenu de la
dégradation de notre balance commerciale
et de la baisse de leur taux de
marge dispositif simple au demeurant
puisque le crédit d'impôt représentait 4
% et aujourd'hui 6 % de la masse
salarial jusqu'à deux fois et demi le
SMIC contrairement aux autres mesures de
la politique de l'emploi le cice n'est
donc pas un complément d'allèigement des
cotisations sociales mais une sorte de
super niche fiscale accordé aux
entreprises qu'ell soit assujetti à
l'impôt sur le revenu ou à l'impôt sur
les sociétés toutefois comme les
exonérations de cotisation sociale le C
ce part du même postulat celui d'un coup
du travail qui serait trop élevé à aucun
moment ne son ne sont analys les coûts
du capital qu'il s'agisse de la
rémunération des actionnaires comme des
services financiers et bancaires c'est
donc une niche fiscale accordé au moment
où l'on constate la hausse de la
contribution des redevables de l'impôt
sur le revenu imposé au titre des
salaires traitement retraites et
pensions et celle de la TVA dont le taux
normal est aujourd'hui de 20 %. deux
mesures prises pour réduire les déficits
et redresser les comptes de la Nation le
cice devrait restaurer la compétitivité
de nos entreprises entre guillemets
rétablir leur Marg toujours entre
guillemets conditions syineéquanom de
leurs futurs investissements c'est en
tout cas ce que l'on nous annonçait pour
la première fois peut-être l'argent
public est ouvertement et effectivement
utilisé à restaurer les marges de nos
entreprises à dire vrai les éléments
assez fragmentaires fournis par le
comité de suivi en mis en place autour
des services de France stratégie et de
monsieur
pisaniferri ne donne pas d'outil de
mesure des investissements et des
crédations d'emploi dans les entreprises
bénéficiant de ce crédit d'impôt la
lecture du document de suivi de France
stratégie ne fournit pour leure qu'un
suivi des intentions d'embauche et
d'investissement des bénéficiaires il
aura donc fallu fallu selon la formule
utilisée environ un an pour les
entreprises
pour que les entreprises fassent
l'apprentissage du cice et 6 à 8 mois
supplémentaires pour que cet
apprentissage ne se traduisent
virtuellement par des intentions à
investir dans un premier temps ou à
embaucher dans un second temps par
réponse à l'enquête de conjoncture de
l'INC on peut donc se demander combien
de temps il faudra pour que les
intentions deviennent réalités et se
traduisent par une relance de
l'investissement productif et des
créations d'emplois dans le numéro de ce
mois d'octobre le mensuel alternative
économique nous montre qu'au moins l'une
des raisons du soutien du meddeef au
cice a été atteint en effet au second
trimestre 2014 les entreprises
françaises malgré leur faible taux de
marge et leur compétitivité chancelante
ont distribué rien moins que 40,7
milliards d'euros de dividendes à leurs
actionnaires un montant en hausse de 30
% sur l'exercice précédent nous précise
le mensuel ce qui montre que nos
entreprises ont sinon retrouvé leur
rentabilité en tout cas qu'elles
tiennent leurs promesses vis-à-vis de
leurs
actionnaires cette situation est
cependant préoccupante à plus d'un titre
puisqu'il semble bien que si
investissement et effort il y a eu c'est
pour capter la clientèle disponible des
marchés dit émergent au détriment du
marché
domestique ce qui veut dire que le
mouvement de délocalisation des
productions continues et que le jeu sur
les prix de transfert justifie plus
encore la nécessité de la transparence
sur l'activité de nos grands groupes à
vocation internationale dans chaque pays
où ils sont implantés il y a chers
collègues beaucoup de noms dit autour du
Crédit Impôt compétitivité emploi de ce
qu'il représente de ce à quoi il tend de
sa quotité de son affectation de son
poids dans les finances publiques et il
me semble que nous devons faire effort
pour comprendre en quoi la mesure est
est discutable et doit à notre sens être
finalement
abandonné ce que nous dit le comité de
suivi est assez éclairant quand bien
même nous ne serions que souligner
encore nombre d'appréciations très
évaluative dans le rapport de ce comité
notons que le cice ne semble pas avoir
coûté aux finances publiques autant que
cela était prévu sauf qu'arrêter son
coût pour les finances publiques à la
seule lecture du montant de la créance
d'impôt sur les sociétés ou d'impôts sur
le revenu imputable me semble quelque
peu limitatif en réalité avec un budget
de l'État dont le montant de dépenses
budgétairees et fiscales atteint environ
675 milliards d'euros marqué par
l'émission de 180 milliards d'euros de
titre de dette publique destiné à
amortir l'existant ou à financer le
déficit budgétaire que voit-on que pour
2 € de
cice il faut le 1 € de ressources extra
budgétair et que la moitié de cette
somme va se trouver imputée sur le
déficit budgétaire constaté en pratique
en
2015 17,4 milliards d'euros seront
mobilisés selon le comité de suivi pour
financer le
cice l'État va donc émettre 8 milliards
d'euros de ressources extra budgétaires
pour le payer aux entreprises
bénéficiaires et le déficit public s'en
trouvera majoré de 3 à 3 milliards et
demi d'euros un tel coût de court et
moyen terme pour les finances publiques
implique que nous nous interrogions sur
la réalité et l'efficacité de la
politique menée à travers cette mesure
particulièrement pour l'emploi quelques
exemples en or par patcalais
19654 entreprises disposa de 2 242
millions vous voyez j'ai même du mal moi
à à mesurer l'ampleur donc disposer de
242,2 millions d'euros de créances cice
en 2014 soit une moyenne de 12320 € de
créance par entreprise pour beaucoup de
l'argent de poche pour d'autres un vrai
pactol dans l'enquête sur les besoins de
main d'œuvre réalisés pour 2014 par Pôle
emploi dans ce département dans cette
région plutôt les entreprises font état
de
80511 projets d'embauche dont 20 28 % de
projets saisonniers le top 5 des
professions les plus demandées
animateurs socio-culturels agents
d'entretien de locaux aide à domicile
emploi de libre service aide soignant le
tout représentant plus de 23 % des
offres d'emploi potentiel de l'année
tous des emplois non
délocalisables la hausse des projet
d'embauche est de 2700 offres en un an
en région Loren 1239 entreprise se
partage une créance de 143,8 millions
l'enquête besoin de main- d'œuvre 2014
indique
44282 offres d'emploi potentiel dont
plus de 28 % de saisonniers là encore
6600 projets d'embauche en plus après 3
années de baisse consécutives dont les
2/ers dans le domaine des services et de
fait les emplois peu ou pas qualifiés
dans les différentes branches du secteur
prenons la Bretagne
90213 projets d'embauche en 2014 ont été
indiqués par les entreprises des quatre
départements dont près de 40 % dans des
emplois saisonniers la part des offres
de contrat saisonniers est même de 50 %
dans les Côtes d'Armor de près de 55 %
dans le Finistère et atteint ou dépasse
70 % sur les bassins d'emplois de
quimperl Concarneau aay ou encore
l'agneau mais
16864 entreprises bretonnes ont
bénéficié d'une créance de cice de 22
12,9 million d'euros en 2014 probable
que les abattoirs Gad ou le volalier
doux ont touché aussi du
cice à ce stade je ne peux cependant
manquer de souligner la situation d'une
entreprise de ma région à savoir la
société radiale implanté notamment dans
mon département l'INDR etloire mais
aussi dans l'iser entreprise spécialisé
dans la production de composants
électroniques radial est une entreprise
dite de taille intermédiaire créée par
Rivon gataz et reprise depuis par son
fils Pierre actuel président du meddeef
comme son père fut président du
cmpf cette anné cette année radial va
payer en France 202000 € d'impôts sur
les sociétés pour un chiffre d'affaires
au niveau du groupe de 235 millions
d'euros et un bénéfice de près de 25
millions elle va bénéficier de
876000 € de créan cice à épuiser d'ici
2017 une telle situation après réflexion
c'est le moins que l'on puisse dire
puisque cela justifie que radial
bénéficiera d'une créance reportable sur
les exercices ultérieurs de la même
manière que la société a pu ces
dernières années alléger ses obligations
fiscales françaises du coût de son
expansion à l'étranger dans des pays au
cieux fiscaux plus cléments et aux
obligations sociales moins
pesantes pierre Gatas é un habile chef
d'entreprise si l'essentiel de ses
salariés de son chiffre d'affaires
demeure réalisé en France la plus grande
partie de sa plus-value est transférée à
l'étranger merveille de l'optimisation
fiscale sujet cher à mon collègue ériic
boet qui permet d'imputer les pertes
liées au coût de délocalisation des
productions sur les profits ultérieurs
et de se servir de ses base à
l'international pour distribuer au mieux
les profits et éviter les impositions
trop élevées
le cice ne paiera peut-être pas les 2,8
millions de dividendes que s'accordent
les actionnaires de radial 87 % des
parts appartiennent quand même à la
famille gatase mais il leur permettra
par contrecût de les financer encore
plus
aisément notons pour l'anecdote que
Pierre gataz lui-même s'est ainsi vu
accorder 247000 € de dividend somme
supérieur à l'impôt payé par son groupe
et qu'il bénéficiera pour cela il ne le
rappelle pas sur son site personnel et
cette information doit à mon sens être
portée à la connaissance de tous de
98800 € de crédit d'impôt au titre des
dividendes perçues pour le reste il faut
rappeler que c'est au niveau des plus
grandes entreprises c'est-à-dire pour
l'administration fiscale de la direction
des grandes entreprises et de la
direction des résidents à l'étranger des
services généraux que se concentre
l'essentiel de la créance cice ces deux
direction ont inventorié 0,7 % des
entreprises bénéficiaires du crédit
d'impôt qui ont capté pour leur compte
42,6 % de la créance soit plus de 3,5
milliards d'euros au
total je ne sais si ces entreprises ont
eu ou non un temps d'apprentissage ou
d'adaptation cice mais apparemment
certaines apprennent plus vite que
d'autres pour les grandes entreprises la
créance moyenne se situe à 1 million
d'euros par
entreprise qui sont qui semble si l'on
en croit le mensuel économique que je
citais tout à l'heure avoir été mise à
profit pour assurer le respect des
décisions d'assemblée générale
d'actionnaires en matière de
distribution de dividendes et de retour
sur investissement comme ils le disent
avec
élégance doit-on en conclure que le cice
n'a provoqué aucune inf inflexion
significatif des politiques d'embauche
de nos entreprises il semble bien
malheureusement que ce soit le cas
puisque leur rapport de la mission
d'information de l'Assemblée nationale
sur le crédit d'impôt au rapport carré
mais en évidence que nous ne sommes pas
sortis de la quadrature du cercle le
cice n'a eu qu'un effet directement
constaté celui de modérer la progression
d'un nouvel indice à savoir l'indice du
coût du travail un indice qui ne fait
pas la une des médias grand public
puisque sa modération signifie tout
simplement que les les salaires ont
tendance à stagner dans notre pays ce
n'est pas une situation nouvelle en
France puisque depuis que l'État gèle le
point d'indice des fonctionnaires il
semble inspirer bien des politiques
salariales dans le secteur dit
concurrentiel devrais-je en conclure que
le dressement le redressement de la
rentabilité de nos entreprises de leur
marge passe par une nouvelle contraction
de la masse salariale on pourrait en
conclure cela il y a dans le débat sur
le CCE en effet une réelle hypocrisie
alors même que les coûts de production
ne se limitent aucunement au seul coût
du travail c'est bel et VI sur ce seul
élément que porte depuis plus de 20 ans
tous les efforts des politiques
publiques dites de l'emploi si l'on
accepte les lois au BR sur l'aménagement
et la réduction du temps de travail
c'est seulement à l'ône de la
contraction des coûts salariaux que le
mesure les choses ce n'est qu'à travers
ce prisme qu'est mesuré la compétitivité
de notre industrie ce n'est pas comme
nous l'avons vu en développant l'emploi
saisonnier l'emploi précaire les emplois
dans les secteurs peu qualifiés que nous
montrons en
que nos produits seront compétitifs à
l'exportation au demeurant comme chacun
l'aura constaté à la lectures du rapport
carré comme de celui du comité de suivi
les secteurs bénéficiaires du cice ne
sont pas spécifiquement plus exposés à
la concurrence internationale que les
autres ainsi lors du séminaire de la
commission des finances en région Centre
les services fiscaux nous ont confirmé
que les principaux bénéficiaires du cice
dans cette région étaient les sociétés
de travail temporaire et les groupe de
la grande distribution quant à la
fameuse compétitivité des services aux
entreprises en Allemagne que l'on nous
présente souvent comme une véritable
réussite elle est fondée vous le savez
sur des pratiques de dumping social
forcené et aujourd'hui 20 % des salariés
allemands sont embauchés à temps partiel
pour des rémunérations inférieures à 5 €
de l'heure c'est cela le modèle de
compétitivité qu'on veut nous vendre
coûte que coûte et qui semble d'ailleurs
cet an dernier légèrement en panne
c'est une illustration de plus des
principes de concurrence libre et non
foncé à la mode
européenne parlons quelques instants des
perspectives offertes sur le moyen terme
par le cice comme le rappelle le rapport
carré trois modèles macroéconomiqu ont
été conçus pour évaluer les effets du
cice en terme d'emploi de croissance ou
encore d'échang extérieur sans surprise
le modèle le plus optimiste est celui de
la direction du Trésor qui tente
d'expliquer que la perte des ressources
fiscales causées par le cice 17,5
milliards d'euros en 2015 serait
compensé par une progression du PIB
situé entre 0,9 et 1,1 % sur la période
2017 à 2022 soit entre 22 et 25
milliards il est évident que ni le
trésor ni monsieur Macron alors
conseiller à l'Élysée n'avait intérêt à
minorer les effets positifs attendus par
la mise en œuvre du crédit d'impôt même
si l'effet levier ver faible en terme
d'emploi le modèle du Trésor évoque
396000 créations d'emploi à l'horizon
2017 avant d'être parlementaire j'ai été
enseignante en école élémentaire j'ai
faire beaucoup de calcul mental
contrairement à ce que l'ont dit mais
faisons une simple division 66,1
milliards d'euros de créances cice prévu
à l'horizon
2017 par
396000 emplois créés attendus nous
aboutissons à une charge unitaire de
près de 167000 € par emploi créé ce
n'est plus de l'emploi aidé mes chers
collègues c'est de l'emploi privé sous
perfusion de fonds publics et ce à fond
perdus à ce niveau de coût il vaut
peut-être mieux assurer l'équilibre de
l'assurance chômage et créer des emplois
publics cela coûtera moins cher aux
finances publiques et quand je lis
Martine Aubri dans le JDD elle ne semble
pas loin de faire la même analyse quand
elle dit 20 milliards d'euros peuvent
être libéré et elle précise même je
propose un soutien avec ces 20 milliards
à la croissance qui touche les ménages
et les collectivités locales il est par
ailleurs à craindre qu'un autre effet
pervers n'accompagne le cice comme le
montre nombre de réponses fournies par
les professionnels des différents
secteurs d'activité interrogés autant
par le comité pisanifée que par la
Mission carré les entreprises utilisent
d'abord le cice pour investir
c'est-à-dire que la créance peut fort
bien servir à assurer l'autofinancement
de certaines acquisitions mais aussi
c'est à craindre à permettre les
investissements sub substituant le
capital matériel au capital humain
c'est-à-dire la machine à l'emploi en
clair le cice permettrait d'accélérer
les processur les processus dit de
modernisation accompagné de suppression
de postes de travail l'évaluation
beaucoup plus modeste retenue par l'OFCE
sur l'incidence du crédit d'impôt et
notamment son faible impact sur la
croissance atteste clairement que les
arbitrages de dernier ressort n'ont pas
forcément vocation à développer la
production par de chaque entreprise pour
Mathieu PL concepteur du modèle de
l'OFCE le cice devrait conduire à la
création de 150000 emplois au bout des 5
ans de mise en place et générer un gain
de croissance de 0,1 point de PIB en
2018 le cu ce ne sert peut-être tout
simplement qu'à réduire les coûts
salariaux pour accroître la rémunération
du capital c'est en tout cas le choix
nous semble-t-il que certaines sociétés
ont fait c'est pourquoi à tout le moins
madame la ministre nous devrions en
toute transparence connaître les sommes
dont chaque entreprise bénéficie pour
mieux apprécier l'utilisation des fonds
public qu'elles reçoivent nous le
demandons bien nous élus aux
associations dans toutes nos
collectivités d'cun s'interroge
cependant sur la possibilité de modifier
la nature du cice et de l' transformer
en allègement complémentaire de
cotisation sociale l'hypothèse est
avancée dans le rapport carré qui voit
l'opportunité de réduire les cotisations
sociales et de financer par exemple la
disparition des cotisations dites
patronal destiné à la branche famille on
aura constaté qu'avant de réduire
définitivement les cotisations c'est aux
prestations de cette branche que l'on
s'attaque mais l'hypothèse du rapport
carré n'est rien d'autre qu'une idée
défendue par le parti même de
l'intéressé l'UMP en matière de
politique publique dès le 15 décembre
2012 date du débat parlementaire sur
l'article créant le cicece que le Sénat
avait rejeté par scrutin public nos
collègues artui de lae de Montgolfier de
lâre intervenaient tous pour légitimité
le remplacement du crédit d'impôt par ce
qu'ils appellent les allègements de
charges financés au demeurant par la
hausse de la TVA et que nous appelons
pour notre part des baisses de salairire
plutôt que de s'interroger sur le bien
fondé de dépenser de 17 milliards à 22
milliards à alléger la légitime
contribution fiscale des entreprises
elle bénéficie en en effet de la dépense
publique elle aussi les porte-paroles
donc que je viens de citer préféraent
voir dans le cice un levier de plus pour
mener leur action de longue haleine
contre le financement solidaire de la
protection sociale que le cice entend
permettre la restauration des marches
des entreprises leur compétitivité ou
que les allégements de cotisation
sociales cherchent à alléger le coût du
travail tout cela ne constitue que les
deux phases de la même logique qu'on
réduise le salaire socialisé en
supprimant des cotisation sociale ou
qu'on restaure les marges des
entreprises on vise dans tous les cas à
accroître les profits quel que soit
d'ailleurs la réalité de la production
dans tous les cas le partage de la
valeur ajoutée créée de manière
exclusive par le travail des salariés
leur est chaque fois plus défavorable et
s'aligne à contrario à la hausse quand
il s'agit de payer la rentre des
banquiers ou de rémunérer les
actionnaires la société que nous voyons
s'esquisser derrière ces choix est
encore plus dur que celle d'aujourd'hui
le travail y sera toujours plus mal
rémunéré toujours plus précarisé la
formation des travailleurs toujours
méprisé leur qualification toujours
moins reconnu pendant que les
actionnaires percevront toujours plus de
dividendes dans une course au maintien
d'une haute rentabilité des
investissements madame la Présidente
m'ayant demandé d'accélérer euh je
voudrais j'ai j'ai dépassé je je je
constate en effet que j'ai dépassé je
vais donc
conclure oh quand même pas faut-il que
nous dépensions des sommes fort
importantes pour créer selon les
estimations 152000 à 396000 emplois dans
les 5 années qui qui viennent et je vous
le rappelle ce qui ne représente que 1 à
2,5i % de l'emploi privé nous ne le
pensons pas il est grand temps que les
politique de soutien aux entreprises et
où à l'activité sorte de l'ornière des
allègements de fiscalité ou de
cotisation sociale pour aller au cœur
des enjeux la qualité de financement de
l'investissement productif la
progression des rémunérations et des
qualification la réduction du temps de
travail rendu possible par les
évolutions technologiques voilà ce qui
devrait guider l'action publique en
direction des entreprises et
particulièrement le rôle de la BPI
devrait être réinterrogé dans ce sens
merci ma cher collègue essayez de
respecter le
temps dans la suite du débat la parole
est à Monsieur Stéphane Ravier vous avez
la parole mon cher collègue
oui merci madame la Présidente vous
venez à la tribune ch collèg s'il vous
pl
plî on voit les
nouveaux bien madame madame la
Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs mes chers collègues ce débat
sur le cice est pertinent à condition de
replacer ce débat sur des bases saines
en regardant la réalité économique en
face la réalité c'est que le cice est
sinon une perte du moins un sacrifice
pour les finances publiques et pourquoi
l'État sacrifie-t-il ainsi de la
ressource fiscale qui pourrait qui
devrait financer ces missions
régaliennes où les Français l'attendent
notamment la sécurité puisqu'en France
aujourd'hui ce sont les école qui brûle
ou encore sur la défense nationale dont
le budget sera une fois encore raboté
cette année alors que notre armée est
engagée aux quatre coins du globe un
sacrifice pour payer sans aucun doute
les pots cassé du sans frontiérisme
bruxellois qui mine notre
compétitivité en faisant de notre pays
un espace ouvert à tous les
vents en particulier au vent mauvais de
la concurrence déloyal d'un côté on
assomme nos entreprises avec la
concurrence déloyale venue de pays qui
ne respecte aucune norme qu'elle soit
sociale économique environnementale
sanitaire voire même syndicale mais
aussi avec la hausse de la TVA qui les
oblige à réduire leur Marg pour ne pas
augmenter leur prix tout en reversant
davantage à l'état de l'autre on leur
rend quelqu argent mais sans cibler le
le secteur en particulier rien
d'étonnant dès lors à ce que le cice
n'atteigne pas ses objectifs nous sommes
loin d' 13 milliards promis aux
entreprises mais surtout le système
profite davantage aux emplois non
délocalisables qu'à l'industrie la
construction qui continue de perdre du
terrain dans notre pays avec
respectivement 8100 et 8800 postes
perdus au premier semestre
2014 la solution est ailleurs non pas le
repli sur soi non pas fermer les
frontières personne ici n'a pour
ambition de faire de notre pays la Corée
du Nord de l'Europe mais simplement
protéger intelligemment enfin nos
intérêts économiques et par la même nos
entreprises comme le font toutes les
grandes démocraties du monde comme le
font les grands pays mais ailleurs qu'en
Europe dès lors nous n'aurons plus
besoin d'une usine à gaz coûteuse comme
le cice je vous
remercie merci mon cher collègu la
parole est à Monsieur Vincent de de la
vous avez la
parole madame la présidente madame la
ministre mes chers
collègues depuis décembre 2012 nous
n'avons guère eu d'occasion d'évoquer
spécifiquement le dispositif du CCE en
séance publique je souhaite donc
remercier nos collègues du groupe
communiste
d'avoir demandé ce débat sur le bilan de
de son
application en effet les conditions de
la création de ce crédit d'impôt ont été
particulièrement
confuse le rapport Louis Galois à peine
publié en novembre 2012 le gouvernement
a souhaité en prendre immédiatement acte
en introduisant dans le dans la 3è loi
de finance rectificative pour 2012 un
amendement portant création de ce
nouveau
dispositif un amendement à 20 milliards
d'euros c'est rarissime et même
peut-être historique je n'ai pas
vérifié heureusement d'ailleurs car
cette méthode est bien avantageuse pour
le gouvernement pas d'étude d'impact peu
de débat en commission et pour nous
sénateurs le sentiment d'être placé
devant le fait accompli en séance
publique lorsque vous constatez que
l'Assemblée nationale a introduit dans
le texte un tel
dispositif c'était démocratiquement un
peu léger madame la ministre pour un
crédit d'impôt reposant sur une
enveloppe de 20
milliards dans ces conditions de
présentation il faut bien le dire aussi
d'improvisation il était logique à
l'époque que le Sénat dans sa grande
sagesse rejette l'adoption de ce crédit
d'impôt j'étais d'ailleurs à titre
personnel cosignataire de l'amendement
qui avait supprimé l'article avant que
le Sénat finisse par rejeter l'ensemble
du PLFR de
2012 au-delà des arguments de forme
trois motifs de fond justifi il y a 2
ans ce
rejet les conditions de financement du
cice le faible impact prévisible du
dispositif et son moindre avantage en
comparaison de la TVA sociale il me
semble trop tôt aujourd'hui pour faire
un bilan complet du dispositif et de son
impact
macro-économique on peut néanmoins avoir
une première idée de son efficacité à
venir à travers les modalités de son
lancement qu'en est-il donc du cice
après 2 années
d'application première question quel a
été l'impact du dispositif ces deux
dernières années dès l'origine l'analyse
par les sénateurs du groupe UD UC du
cice et des modalités de son application
nous le faisait percevoir non pas comme
il aurait dû l'être comme un outil
d'amélioration de la compétitivité des
entreprises mais plutôt comme un outil
de conservation de l'emploi dans les
grands groupes de
services en effet le cice n'est pas une
baisse des charges sociales mais un
crédit d'impôt sur les bénéfices sur
ceux qui en font en tout cas que ces
derniers soient assujettis au régime de
l'IS ou de l'IR ce crédit est ass sur
l'évolution de la masse salariale
jusqu'à de CEIC et
demi aussi plus vous êtes une grande
entreprise plus vous employez de
personne plus leurs rémunération
moyennes sont basses plus vous êtes
bénéficiaire du
cice inversement une start-up ou une
petite entreprise qui emploie des
ingénieurs de haut niveau rémunéré
au-delà de demic et demi est de facto
exclu de l'assiette du crédit
d'impôt l'exemple de la Poste est
particulièrement significatif de ce
phénomène elle est l'une des premières
bénéficiaires de ce dispositif et
pourtant elle ne semble pas être la
cible première du cice il ne s'agit pas
d'emploi industriel et à forceori ce
n'est pas à travers le soutien de ce
type de groupe que la France va résoudre
son problème de
compétitivité l'effet principal du
dispositif sont donc plutôt de
récompenser les grands groupes qui font
un effort pour dynamiser leur masse
salariale plutôt que les entreprises
soumises à la compétition mondiale et
qui se battent à
l'export le rapport d'information de
l'Assemblée nationale indique que plus
d'un million 200000 entreprises ont
bénéficié en moyenne du dizaine de
milliards d'euros au titre du
CCE or il apparaît dans ce même rapport
que les PME ne représentent que la
moitié des sommes versées alors qu'elles
représentent plus de 95 % des
entreprises il est donc manifeste qu'une
poignée de grands groupes s'accapare
près de la moitié des fonds versés
cette dichotomie entre les grands
groupes et les entreprises de taille
plus modeste n'est pas non plus sans
effet structurel dans le paysage
entrepreneurial en effet si l'on prend
l'exemple du secteur du bâtiment le cice
a renforcé la différence entre les
grands groupes bénéficiire du cice et
leurs sous-traitants de taille plus
modeste parfois des artisans des
indépendants ou des
au-entrepreneurs exclus de fait du champ
d'application du
dispositif en matière d'emploi
industriel ou de renforcement des
entreprises tournées vers l'exportation
cible privilégié du rapport de Louis
Gallois et à juste titre le constat est
sans appel près de 35 % des montants
versés au titre du crédit d'impôt sont
destinés à des secteurs non exposés à la
concurrence internationale la
restauration l'hôtellerie mais aussi le
spectacle l'enseignement et même
l'administration publique entre autres
voire les
associations l'emploi industriel et les
secteurs explosés ne sont donc pas la
cible unique du C
ce dans tous les cas le cice demeure
sous-employé d'après le rapport il
faudrait attendre
2018 pour que la créance du CSE dépasse
la barre des 20 milliards d'euros qui
était initialement l'objectif de
départ d'après les chiffres fournis par
le rapport d'information de l'Assemblée
nationale cela signifie que près de de
14,8 milliards d'euros n'auront pas été
alloués au financement du cicece pendant
4 ans c'est autant d'efforts
supplémentaires sans contre partie
demander à nos
concitoyens tout cela pose donc la
question du financement du
dispositif en effet le crédit d'impôt a
été financé par une enveloppe
prévisionnelle de 20 milliards d'euros
qui devait être appuyé sur la hausse de
la TVA c'est-à-dire le passage du TR
principal de 196 à 20 et du taux
intermédiaire de 7 à 10 % d'un effort
sur les dotations des collectivités et
de la mise en place d'une nouvelle
fiscalité
écologique rétrospectivement ces
annonces prête à sourire sauf pour les
collectivités en effet en ce qui
concerne la TVA cela signifie qu'un
crédit d'impôt ciblé sur les grands
groupes est financé par l'ensemble de la
population et l'ensemble des
entreprises dans le secteur du bâtiment
ce mode de financement renforce une fois
de plus la différence entre les grands
groupes et leurs sous-traitants puisque
de fait le cice ça apparente alors à un
transfert net de fond des petits groupes
vers les grands ce qui ne peut à terme
que favoriser la concentration dans ce
secteur pour le reste la fiscalité
écologique est au point mort avec la
polémique interminable sur lesécotaxes
et ses avatars quant à l'effort des
collectivités il est désormais dédié au
financement des baisses de charges
sociales annoncé dans le cadre du PACT
de responsabilité qui sont
complémentaires il n'en demeure pas
moins que le mode de financement est
surdimensionné par rapport aux demandes
réelles d'accès au
cice cela signifie donc que sous couvert
d'un effort en faveur de la
compétitivité des entreprises le
gouvernement a subreptissement fait
passer une hausse de TVA dédié à
l'assaainissement des finances publiques
moins de 6 mois après avoir supprimé la
TVA compétitivité proposé en février
2012 par le gouvernement de François
Fillon lors de sa première loi de
finance rectificative pour
2012 cette astuce est renforcée par la
logique du
préfinancement en effet le CCE est
préfinancé par la banque publique
d'investissement et les banques
commerciales et par la créance que les
entreprisees constatent sur le budget de
l'État concrètement les entreprises
constatent à la fin de l'annéeen
qu'elles ont une créance sur le budget
de l'État or la dette correspondante à
cette créance n'est pas prise en compte
dans le budget de la même année c'est
effectivement très astucieux mais pas
bien respectueux du principe de
sincérité des comptes publicques madame
les
ministres encore aujourd'hui le passage
à un régime de TVA social nous apparaît
plus efficace que l'actuelle CCE et cela
pour au moins trois
raisons première raison le CCE introduit
une forme d'injustice dans la politique
fiscale des
entreprises tout le monde contribue à
son financement mais tous n'en
bénéficient pas j'ai déjà évoqué les
distorsions dont le cice pourrait être
la cause dans certaines branches je n'y
reviendrons reviendrai donc pas la TVA
sociale est universelle et concerne tout
le monde dsors qu'elle permet de baisser
les charges sociales qui pèsent sur
toutes les entreprises de
l'auto-entrepreneur à la
multinationale deuxème raison le cise
est complexe non déplais au rapport de
l'Assemblée nationale qui vend sa Simp
ce dispositif demande une déclaration
une procédure d'attribution et un suivi
national et régional sans oublier les
conditions particulièrement lourdes et
complexes de son
préfinancement la TVA sociale est claire
simple et lisible vous augmentez la TVA
vous affectez le produit supplémentaire
à la sécurité sociale et vous baissez en
conséquence les charges sociales et cela
sur une même
année trè raison la TVA sociale a des
effets plus sensibles sur l'emploi et
sur la comptivité en effet en ciblant la
baisse des charges et pas un simple
crédit d'impôt en le finançant par une
hausse sensible du taux principal de TVA
ce mécanisme permet de taxer la
consommation de produits importés tout
en favorisant la production
nationale il s'agit ainsi de financer le
redressement de notre capacité de
production et de notre protection
sociale en renchérissant les prix de nos
compétiteurs
étrangers cette logique ver vertueuse
est un vecteur de croissance de
développement de nos entreprises de
baisse du coût du travail il stimule
l'offre nationale et donc l'emploi de
nos
concitoyens nurait n'aurait-il pas été
plus simple madame la ministre
d'amplifier le dispositif de TVA
compétitivité voté en février 2012
plutôt que de perdre une année à mettre
en place le cice pour annoncer encore un
an plus tard un nouveau plan de baisse
des charges via le PACT de
responsabilité
sans lier le financement des
deux d'un côté nous avons une hausse
sous-employé de la TVA et de l'autre la
promesse d'une baisse hypothétique de la
dépense publique sauf pour les
collectivités qui vont vraiment voir
leurs ressources
diminuer en conclusion dans le contexte
de tension fiscale actuelle et de
dégradation de la compétitivité de nos
entreprises tout ce qui va dans le sens
du soutien au secteur marchand est une
bonne
nouvelle le cice est un ainsi la seule
véritable mesure fiscale intéressant le
fonctionnement de l'économie réelle qui
était qui a été prise depuis mai
2012 malheureusement ce crédit d'impôt a
raté une partie de sa cible et c'est
bien dommage le diagnostic et les
propositions de Louis Galois étai clair
notre économie et nos entreprises
avaient besoin et ont toujours besoin
d'un dispositif clair et efficace pour
soutenir l'innovation l'exportation la
compétitivité et donc l'emploi
industriel à l'arrivée à vouloir être
trop écuménique entre l'industrie et les
services vous avez produit un crédit
d'impôt dont l'effet d'entraînement
économique est finalement trop faible
pour stimuler la compétitivité la
croissance et
l'emploi en dépit de nos réticences
initiales le groupe udi UC a essayé de
modifier ce mécanisme nous avons par
exemple déposé à de nombreuses reprises
des amendements afin d'ouvrir le cice
aux indépendants et aux artisans et
pourtant le constat s'impose avec une
certaine évidence il aurait été plus
simple plus rapide plus lisible et plus
efficace de mettre en œuvre une
véritable TVA
sociale le Premier ministre manuel vas
avait jadis vanté ses mérites nous
attendons donc qu'il soit enfin fidèle à
ses premières convictions je vous
remercie merci cher
collègue la parole est à Monsieur Jean
du groupe
UMP présidente madame la
présidente madame la présidente madame
la ministre mes chers collègues
aujourd'hui dans notre semaine de
contrôle le groupe communiste a eu
dirais-je la bonne idée de nous proposer
un débat sur le crédit d'impôt
compétitivité et emploi le
cice cette initiative correspond tout à
fait à l'actualité puisque nous
disposons depuis quelques jours d'un
premier bilan de ce dispositif 20 mois
après son entrée en vigueur ce qui est
ce qui permet de faire une première
évaluation parallèlement je tiens à
mentionner le travail très intéressant
de nos collègues députés dans le cadre
de la mission d'information que préside
notre collègue Olivier
carré bien entendu je gage que nos
collègues communistes pour des raisons
qui nous séparent à l'évidence et
profondément ont choisi d'aborder ce
sujet nous l'avons entendu sous l'angle
de la distribution des dividendes des
profits détournés et encore je dirais
pour éviter les questions de personne en
tous les cas au-delà des dispositions de
la législation sur le
CCE certes on constate que certaines
grandes entreprises dans lesquelles
l'État actionnaire est par exemple la
poste ou les SNCF bénéficie ou ont
bénéficié largement du CCE et qu'ells
ont pourtant une politique de
distribution des dividendes généreuses
voir il faut le le reconnaître un faible
niveau
d'embauche cependant en y regardant de
plus près les 3/4 du cice à ce jour
bénéficient à des PME ou à des
entreprise de taille intermédiaire
entreprises qui réalisent l'essentiel de
leur activité en France contrairement
aux grandes entreprises côé dont nous
sommes également je dois le dire très
fiers je me permettrai de citer à cette
tribune des éléments de notre collègue
devenu secrétaire d'État Christian Ecker
élu de Lorine dont je suis et demeur
etiselle qui est aussi mon département
tenu en juin 2013 je cite rapporteur de
la commission des finances je ne devrais
sans doute pas écrire les lignes qui
suivent quoique ce qui me frappe depuis
un an
presque jour pour jour que je travaille
avec le gouvernement sur les questions
budgétaires c'est le nombre de
contradictions auxquelles nous devons
faire face puis sur le ce il ajoute il
évoque les effets d'ben garantis mais
aussi les effets pervers
assurés les artisans sans salariés
regarderont passer le train alors que
les entreprises et notamment les grosses
entreprises du BTP verront ou verrai
leur impôts diminuer avait-il vu juste
toujours est-il que s'agissant du BTP
c'est un secteur aujourd'hui qui souffre
terriblement mais l'enjeu du CCE est
ailleurs assurément et le débat sur son
utilisation relève selon nous d'une
approche qui doit embrasser un horizon
plus
large le cice assurément est une mesure
à la disposition des entreprises qui
doit être utilisé en fonction de leurs
besoins de la conjoncture
et de leurs perspectives économiques il
doit créer une dynamique qui sert
l'entreprise qui participe à la
restauration des marges de celle-ci et
qui favorise aussi
l'emploi même si là encore on a pu
constater un éè revirement de la part du
gouvernement avec le
rétropédalage exercice devenu habituel
mais au combien périeux de Monsieur
sapin qui a déclaré au début de ce mois
que l'objectif prier
du CCE n'est pas de créer des impôts
mais d'aider les entreprises je cite à
retrouver les marges qu'elles avaient
perdu 2012 et nous sommes en
2014 il faut donc accepter de concevoir
le cice au regard des objectifs que le
gouvernement lui a signé même si av
avouons-le la confusion règne largement
et qu'il serait utile d'avoir une
politique économique d'encouragement au
entreprise en fait une politique de
l'offre qui serait un bon objectif mais
que assurément et malheureusement le
gouvernement a toutes les difficultés à
réaliser à ce titre permettez-moi mes
chers collègues un petit rappel
historique parce que je ne compte plus
les bricolages ni les improvisations
gouvernementales que ce soit en matière
de fiscalité de cotisation sociale ou de
compétitivité à son arrivée au pouvoir
votre majorité la majorité de s'était
empressé de supprimer la TVA
compétitivité ça a été rappelé par mon
collègue qui parlait juste avant moi par
pure idéologie j'oserais même dire par
dogme ce dispositif avait pourtant le
mérite de la simplicité et de
l'efficacité il s'agissait d'augmenter
la TVA pour compenser les baisses direct
de charg
social vous avez ensuite décidé et mis
en œuvre une politique d'augmentation
massive des impôts à contetend de nos
partenaires européens ce qui
immanquablement a profondément
déstabilisé et pénalisé nos entreprises
dois-je rappeler à cet instant le pic
historique cette année du taux le plus
élevé des prélèvements obligatoires qui
atteint aujourd'hui plus de
56,5 % de notre
PIB cependant contrraat est forcé parce
que le ministre issu de vos rang
monsieur moscovicii avait alors qualifié
de ralbol fiscal vous avez alors pris
conscience des limites de cette
politique économique et fiscale parce
que au-delà de la crise elle n'a
finalement fait qu'aggraver la situation
de notre économie et de nos
entreprises nous le savons tous nos
entreprises souffrent d'un handicap de
compétitivité c'est d'ailleurs ce qui
légitime une politique de
l'offre sur ce point je citerer une fois
n'est pas
coutume une personne dont la compétence
est reconnue de tous Monsieur Thomas
picketti je cite il n'est ni juste ni
efficace de faire reposer l'excès de
financement de notre modèle social sur
la masse salariale du secteur
privé madame la ministre même si
l'analyse ne fait pas l'unanimité dans
votre majorité ça a été rappelé
d'ailleurs par notre collègue à
l'ouverture de notre débat sachez
qu'avec mes collègues de l'UMP et bien
au-delà d'ailleurs je partage les
considérants de ce
diagnostic ainsi après avoir perdu plus
d'une année vous avez décidé la mise en
place d'un AAT de TVA compétitivité le
cice Azad parce qu'il ne s'agit pas
d'une baisse directe des charges
sociales comme le préconisait d'ailleurs
le rapport Galois mais d'une forme de
crédit d'impôt qui est en fait un tour
de passe-p budgétaire puisque l'État
crédite les entreprises avec une année
de décalage permettez-moi à ce stade de
faire deux observations le cice est un
soutien aux entreprises dont la valeur
correspond aux augmentations d'impôts
qu'elles ont subi deuxième observation
vous baissez les charges sociales par un
crédit d'impôt imputé sur l'impôt sur
les sociétés ou l'impôt sur le revenu
avouez qu'en terme de simplicité vous
auriez pu faire mieux et les entreprises
les entrepreneurs nous le disent nous le
répètent là je cite non
pas nomément euh comme ça a été fait par
ma collègue mais je vais simplement vous
citer par exemple le patron des de la
CGPME de mon département et de Lorine
qui déclare le système est compliqué il
coûte cher en gestion et il n'a pas
l'effet qu'aurait pu avoir une simple
baisse des charges sociales aucun cap
une série d'improvisations un choc de
complexité ne sommes-nous pas là face à
une nouvelle usine à gaz bien éloigné
d'ailleurs du choc de
simplification regardons maintenant le
premier bilan du CSE il nous conduit
adresser le constat d'une situation que
je qualifierais de mitiger la montée en
charge du dispositif est lente et le
décalage avec vos prévisions ou
oseris-je dire vos espoirs est
surprenant en tous les cas quand on en
fait la mesure objective initialement
pour 2013 votre prévision était de 13
milliards et nous devions passer à 20
milliards en 2014 or début septembre la
consommation constaté est à peine
supérieure à 5 milliards alors certes il
manque des déclarations d'entreprise
et le lié à l'exercice fiscal puisque
pour certaines elles sont de petite
taille le cice pouvant être utilisé sur
3 ans tenons compte de ce décalage
cependant comment expliquer une telle
frilosité vous nous dites que le
dispositif est ou serait mal connu et
bien écoutez je vous accorde encore à
cet instant le bénéfice du doute mais
sachez que je ne me fais aucune illusion
lorsque l'on écoute les chefs
d'entreprise on constate en fait qu'ils
sont partagés sur la la pertinence du
cice et que sa première utilité faut-il
le rappeler de compenser autant que
faire ce peut et je le redis une partie
des impôts supplémentaires qu'ils ont
subis c'est aussi une compensation de
d'autres mesures que vous avez prises et
qui ont contribué à augmenter le coût du
travail la réforme des retraites les
hausses de salaires notamment du SMIC la
suppression des exonérations d'heur
supplémentaires le compte pénibilité
surtout et aussi ce dispositif apparaît
comme complexe et le coût de son
préfinancement élevé surtout pour les
très petites entreprises dois-je enfin
vous signaler que les chefs
d'entreprises craignent d'une certaine
manière la recrudescence des contrôles
fiscaux et ou sociaux comme c'est le cas
pour le crédit impôt
recherche si certains entrepreneurs
voient malgré tout dans le CCE une forme
de Bouffet d'oxygène pour leur
trésorerie on peut d'ors et déjà
constater que les objectifs que vous AZ
que vous avez assignés pardon au cice
ne sont pas tous atteints quel que soit
le point de vue sur lequel on se place
malgré le cice les marges des
entreprises continuent à se détériorer
l'INC nous a donné récemment les marges
sont passées maintenant sensiblement en
dessous de 30 % 29,4 % en
2014 29,8 en 2013 c'est la descente je
dis pas aux enfers mais c'est une
descente pour l'instant
inexorable ement des entreprises ne
s'est pas non plus amélioré 1er
trimestre 2014 0,6 % 2e trimestre 2014 -
0,7 %. enfin l'emploi le E de cice ne
s'améliore pas non plus oserais-je
rappeler que vous aviez annoncé en 2012
la création de 300000 emplois en 2 ans
grâce à ce
dispositif quant à l'inversion de la
courbe du chômage qui nous était promise
pour la fin 2013 par le président
Hollande
ça n'est plus une plaisanterie la sa
parole a été discréditée et la situation
être grave pour pouvoir même en sourir
il faut simplement la rappeler pour
redonner les responsabilités à chacun et
si je rappelle le point de vue
de l'organisation patronnale du Medef
dans mon département là aussi B on nous
disait c'est simple une entreprise pour
espérer toucher 1000 € par salarié et
pour 10 collaborateurs elle peut toucher
10000 € sauf que pour embaucher
quelqu'un il faut au minimum 20000 €
comment peut-on faire dans la
conjoncture actuelle pour embaucher
autant de
personnel je souhaite simplement
rappeler une évidence c'est que c'est
d'abord et avant tout dans notre
économie le carnet de commande qui fait
l'emploi enfin à terme le financement de
ce dispositif n'est pas
assuré vous avez d'abord annoncé qu'il
serait neutre pour le budget de l'État
cette dépens devait en effet
initialement ça a été rappelé être
financé par la hausse de la TVA
l'introduction d'une taxe
environnementale et une baisse de la
dépense publique vous avez donc annulé
la hausse de la TVA pour mieux la
remettre en vigueur au 1er janvier 2014
belle cohérence la fiscalité
environnementale est d au passage des
cinq ministres à ce jour qui ont qui en
ont eu la charge cette fiscalité
environnementale s'est perdue dans les
limbes il reste la baisse de la dépense
publique qui demeure à notre avis
hypothétique et pour trois raisons nous
estimons que les 50 milliards que vous
envisagez en 3 ans de réduction
notamment pour financer la baisse des
charges et l'équilibre des dépenses
publiques n'est pas réalisable parce que
elle ne répond pas aux objectifs que
vous êtes fixé et parce que nous nous
avons un véritable doute sur votre
capacité à les réaliser vous allez donc
très probablement être confronté à un
effet ciseau la montée en charge du CCE
alors que dans le même temps les la
dépense ne baissera pas à du concurrence
et de notre point de vue tant que les
dépenses publiques ne seront pas
réduites substantiellement nous ne
pourrons pas financer une politique et
c'est regrettable favorable à
l'investissement aujourd'hui les chefs
d'entreprise nous le demande l'État doit
d'abord se réformer se réformer
courageusement et réaliser effectivement
un important programme d'économie mais
nous aurons l'occasion d'en reparler
dans le prochain débat en loi de finan
en fait en dressant ce premier bilan du
CCE force de constater que s'agissant de
la politique de l'offre vous êtes d'une
certaine manière resté au milieu du
gay le cice sera au mieux un ballon
d'oxygène mais constituera pas un
élément fort d'une politique de
compétitivité sa montée en charge est
lente et sa possible consommation sur
trois exercices en fonction des
résultats des entreprises ne répond en
tout cas pas à la situation d'urgence de
nos entreprises nous aurions préféré une
mesure générale simple et à effet
rapide priorité doit donc être donnée à
la logique économique restauration des
marches politique d'investissement et
politique de création d'emploi si
j'osais je dirais il ne suffit pas de
déclarer j'aime l'entreprise il vaut
mieux en apporter aujourd'hui des
preuves concrètes c'est c'est sur ce
sujet que nous seront collectivement
jugés queavez-vous d'ailleurs suivi les
préconisations du rapport Galois qui
préconisait lui une baisse des charges
directe et massive à contrario nous
allons en 2015 nous rrouvver avec trois
dispositifs les exonérations sur les bas
salaires le CCE et les mesures du pacte
de responsabilité est-ce lisible pour
les entreprises je vous le dis non
est-ce cohérent non est-ce efficace j'en
doute fortement votre CCE demure donc
ainsi une mesure isolée restera-t-il
comme certains le disent et je cite
Thomas picketti à nouveau
le symbole de l'échec de votre
quinquenin une verrue incarnant jusqu'à
la caricature l'incapacité du pouvoir en
place à engager une réforme ambitieuse
de notre modèle fiscal et social qui se
contente d'ajouter des couches de
complexité sur un système qui en compte
déjà beaucoup
trop parfois il est douloureux
d'entendre certains des siens témoigner
le CCE ne permet pas la constitution
d'un écosystème favorable à l'entreprise
sur le long terme il n'est pas de notre
point de vue à la hauteur pour recréer
un climat de confiance avec le monde de
l'entreprise dans cette perspective
d'autres mesures nous paraissent
indispensables et j'en citerai 6 en
terminant mon propos le premier
simplifier la vie des entreprises mettre
fin aux contrôles intempestives aux
normes diverses et au formal
inutiles 2è d acccords pour l'emploi
offensif au niveau des branches et des
entreprises trème objectif une relance
d'une politique active et audacieuse de
l'actionnariat
salarié 4è politique une politique
fiscale qui favorise l'investissement je
me permettrai d'ailleurs de rappeler que
tout prélèvement confondu pardon les
entreprises de taille intermédiaire et
les PME françaises pai si on les compare
à leurs homologues allemandes 60 %
d'impôt de plus le Laurin que je suis
frontalier de ce pays souhaite rappeler
ces différences qui sont des différences
qui portent préjudice à la compétitive
et des entreprises entre les pays et
dans nos territoires 5è élément ça a été
abordé d'ailleurs dans certains dans
certaines lois récente la flexis
sécurité sur le marché du travail et
enfin j'y reviens 6e et dernier objectif
une véritable réforme de l'État ce sont
ces mesures madame la ministre que nous
appelons de nos vœux au-delà du seul
cice parce qu'il est temps aujourd'hui
de redonner confiance à nos
entrepreneurs et de créer peut-être
d'abord et avant tout une dynamique
favorable à l'investissement et à
l'emploi je vous
remercie merci chers
collèguo estant monsieur jean-gmain du
groupe
socialiste madame la présidente madame
la ministre mes chers collègues
peut-être vais-je apporter une
tonalité plus
favorable à cette
disposition le 5 le 5 novembre 2012
était présenté le rapport gallois qui
présentait un Pact pour la compétitivité
de l'industrie française il était
largement accepté dans notre pays à la
fois par les entrepreneurs et par tous
ceux qui travaillent sur ce sujet il
indiquait notamment quelle était la
situation d'urgence dans notre pays le
manque de compétitivité et la perte de
muscles économique en France et donc il
proposait le transfert d'une partie des
charges sociales pour faire baisser le
coût du travail afin de pouvoir vendre
moins cher afin de restaurer la marge
des entreprises trop faible en vue de
meilleurs
investissements quelques jours plus tard
après un séminaire gouvernemental
consacré au pacte national pour la
croissance la compétitivité et l'emploi
le Premier ministre annoncé un
allègement de 20 milliards du coût du
travail étalé sur 3 ans portant sur les
salaires compris entre 1 et 2,5 SMIC ce
qui représenterait à terme une baisse de
6 % du coût du travail
et ce cette réforme prenait la forme
d'un crédit d'impôt de 20 milliards pour
les entreprises financé à par égale
par des économies supplémentaires dans
les dépenses publiques et par des
modulations de la TVA et de la fiscalité
écologique premier premier constat à la
fois dans le rapport Galois et à l'issue
du séminaire
gouvernemental sur lequel évidemment
tout le monde n'est pas d'accord mais
que nous nous partageons le poids des
cotisations patronales pesant sur les
salaires est excessif en France et il
est urgent de les
alléger non pas pour faire un cadeau au
patron non pas pour faire un cadeau au
patron mais parce qu'il n'est ni juste
ni efficace de faire reposer à l'excès
le financement de notre modèle social
sur la masse salariale du secteur privé
et de fait lorsque l'on compare la
France au pays disposant d'un état
social d'ampleur comparable notre
principale partic particularité et le
poids de nos cotisations patronales le
tau global est supérieur à 40 %. pour
verser 100 € de salaire brut l'employeur
P plus de 540 € en salaire super brut
dont la moitié pour les cotisations
retraite et chômage et la moitié pour
les cotisations maladie famille
construction formation et cetera donc
deux moitiés très différentes aux
objectifs très différents mais qui
pèsent sur le coû du travail les faits
sont étus il faudra bien continuer à
travailler sur cette question deux
rapports vientre d'être remis dressant
un bilan d'étapes du cice le premier par
le comité de suivi du cice institué par
la loi et présidé par Jean pisaniferri
et le second à l'issue d'une mission
parlementaire présidée par Riv Blin la
mission parlementaire dresse un premier
constat
positif la communication autour our du
dispositif a permis une appropriation
rapide par les entreprises le montant de
la créance est globalement conforme à
ses prévisions le préfinancement
fonctionne et l'utilisation est conforme
aux objectifs et permet notamment de
stabiliser le coût du travail et de
contribuer au redressement du taux de
marge des entreprises et la consultation
du rapport de l'Assemblée nationale page
95 est suivante sur toutes les personnes
qui ont été consultées notamment les
représentants des entreprises indique
que cette ce dispositif qui peut être
amélioré toute dispositif peut être
amélioré les satisfait globalement le
rapport du comité de suivi permet par
ailleurs de lever certaines incertitudes
qui ont pu être soulevé au cours des
dernières semaines notamment concernant
l'impact sur les finances publiques et
l'utilisation que font les entreprises
de cette
ressource cela a été indiqué par
plusieurs intervenants le montant du CE
du cice acquis au titre de 2013 est fixé
à 10,8 milliards d'euros dans le projet
de loi de finance de 2015 ce montant est
inférieur aux dernières prévision
réalisé par la cosos sur la base de la
masse salariale 2013 et qui estimé le
montant pour 2013 à 12,3 milliards c'est
exact plusieurs facteurs peuvent
expliquer cet écart l'imprécision des
prévisions initiales basées sur des
données sociales et non fiscales le non
recours si le montant du cice paraît
insignifiant le rejet pour certains des
formalités administratives l'effet
nouveauté a pu jouer aussi conduisant
certaines entreprises à oublié de
remplir la déclaration du cuce elles ont
dans ce cas 3 ans pour réclamer leur d
la nouvelle convention de comptabilité
nationale impose cependant d'enregistrer
la totalité de la créance en dépenses et
non plus en moindre recette pour l'année
de sa formation concernant l'utilisation
que font les entreprises du cice
l'analyse basé sur les enquêtes de
conjoncture de l'INC montre que les
entreprises comptent utiliser cette
ressource en premier lieu pour
l'investissement et ensuite pour
l'emploi il convient toutefois d'avoir
une lecture prudente de ces chiffres la
question posée par l'inse consiste à
savoir si le cice contribue à augmenter
le résultat d'exploitation et si cela
sera affecté majoritairement à
l'investissement entre 52 et 58 % des
entreprises répondent par l'affirmative
et le cice peut tout aussi bien
favoriser l'amélioration des conditions
de travail les dépenses de formation la
prospection commerciale ce que ne teste
pas l'INC mais que laisse penser
d'autres enquêtes plus restreintes que
celle de l'INC qui confirme la primeur
donnée à l'investissement avant tout en
ce qui concerne l'effet sur l'emploi le
rapport du comité de suivi indique qu'il
s'agit souvent de préserver des emplois
plutôt que de recruter de nouveaux salar
AR toutefois l'investissement a
également un impact indirect sur
l'emploi non pris en compte dans ces
enquêtes concernant les bénéficiaires du
cice il apparaît que les PME et les TPE
bénéficient pleinement du dispositif les
rémunérations moyennes étant plus faible
dans les petites entreprises celles-ci
ont une part plus importante de leur
masse salariale inférieure à 2,5 SMIC on
observe donc bien que plus l'entreprise
est petite et plus la part de l'assiette
cice par rapport à la masse salariale
brute est importante en tout les
entreprises de moins de 50 salariés
recueillent environ 39 % de la créance
totale du cicce soit légèrement plus que
celle de plus de 500 salariés par
ailleurs le commerce et l'industrie
manufacturière sont les deux secteurs
bénéficiant le plus du cice en
proportion du montant total versé et
cette part est légèrement supérieure à
leur poids économique en terme de masse
salariale ces secteurs étant
potentiellement les plus exposés à la
concurrence internationale le dispositif
semble être en mesure d'améliorer la
compétitivité de la France enfin le
préfinancement mis en place pour
permettre aux entreprises de bénéficier
immédiatement de l'apport dans
trésorerie se met en place
progressivement BPI France réalise
l'essentiel du préfinancement des PME et
des ETI notamment grâce à la gratuité
des frais de dossier sur les demandes de
faible montant plus de 2/3 des
entreprises concernées par le
préfinancement font état d'une
solvibilité faible le dispositif a donc
bien trouvé sa cible c'est en
particulier le cas du secteur de la
construction qui consente près de 10 %
des bénéficiaires du préfinancement par
BPI France une plus grande implication
des banques commerciales pourrait
toutefois être recherchée avec la montée
en puissance du dispositif la mission
parlementaire fait des propositions pour
améliorer le cice son trois axes le
renforcement de la communication autour
du cice un renforcement du mécanisme de
suivi et des propositions d'évolution
les deux premiers axes comportent des
propositions bienvenues pour améliorer
la compréhension et l'utilisation de
l'outil notamment pour mieux atteindre
l'objectif politique d'afficher des
contreparties au CCE et plus
généralement au pacte de de
responsabilité renforcer la
communication auprès des TPE et des PME
mieux appliquer les dispositions
relatives au suivi de l'utilisation du
cice dans les comptes annuels des
entreprises encourager le dialogue
social sur l'utilisation
du cice il apparaît par ailleurs urgent
d'installer les comités régionaux de
suivi de suivi du cice qui sont
notamment indispensables à la pleine
mise en œuvre des dispositions de la loi
de sécurisation de l'emploi ces comités
de suivis régionaux devrai se mettre en
place rapidement trois évolutions de
court terme sont également proposées
permettent l'imputation du cice sur les
accomte d'impôts des sociétés afin
d'éviter des mouvements de trésorerie
dans les entreprises permettre au redev
non imposé au réel de revenir sur cette
option normalement valable 10 ans afin
d'être soumise à un régime réel donnant
droit au cice étudier la possibilité
d'accorder au secteur non lucratif un
avantage fiscal similaire au cice de
manière à égaliser les conditions
d'accès au marché publics enfin la
mission propose à terme de transférer le
cice sur un allègement de cotisation
sociale il convient d'être prudent sur
cette évolution mais nul doute que nous
aurons à un repar dans un prochain dans
un prochain débat le cice est l'un des
piliers de la stratégie économique du
gouvernement cette stratégie repose sur
trois éléments réduire le déficit public
et assaignir nos comptes publics
restaurer la compétitivité de l'économie
et ainsi renouer avec plus de croissance
et d'emploi de manière durable enfin
réformer notre économie comme nous le
faisons depuis 2 ans en amplifiant
encore nos efforts des propositions sont
faites sur l'évolution des dispositifs à
moyen terme les patrons F de PME
tiennent au cice ils l'ont indiqué
d'après le baromètre KPMG CGPME ils sont
66 % à craintre une remise en question
prochaine du cice je cite la mesure est
aujourd'hui plébiscitée par les
dirigeants qui commence à mesurer les
premiers bénéfices financiers ils
craignent d'autant plus sa remise en
cause que le degré d'inquiétude face à
la situation économique est important je
pense mes chers collègues que pour un
dispositif qui vient de se mettre en
place et qui montre en puissance le le
cice a réussi sur une grande partie de
son ambition les entreprises ont besoin
d'un message de stabilité et il ne faut
pas du tout les inquiéter les
entrepreneurs rencontrés sur le terrain
s'interroge souvent sur la pérenité du
cice nous devons rassurer les
entreprises sur l'importance de notre
politique visant à soutenir la
compétitivité enfin toute évolution doit
être compatible avec notre engagement à
réd réuire le déficit public madame la
ministre vous l'aurez compris je suis de
ceux qui considèrent que ce cice est
quelque chose de positif et que nous
devons non pas inquiéter les entreprises
en disant qu'il pourrait le supprimer
mais dire simplement qu'il sera
améliorer merci la parole est à Monsieur
André gatolin du groupe
écologie
madame la présidente madame la ministre
mes chers collègues la position des
écologistes sur la mise en place du
crédit d'impôt compétitivité emploi vous
vous en souvenez peut-être avait été au
moment de son annonce très clairement
critique sur la forme d'abord nous
avions regrettter qu'un tel dispositif
soit mis en place sous la forme
d'amendement à une loi loi de finance
rectificative alors que son importance
appelait à davantage de débats de
réflexion et à la production d'une
véritable étude d'impact sur le fond
ensuite ces fidalités nous paraissaient
beaucoup trop flou et son financement
reposant à la fois sur une baisse des
dépenses publiques une hausse de la TVA
et les revenus de ce qu'on annonçait
alors comme une nouvelle fiscalité
écologique nous apparaissait bien mal
calibré 2 ans plus tard et alors que
nous on désormais d'un certain recul
forcé de constater que nos réticences
n'étaient pas tout à fait infondé
entendons-nous bien il ne s'agit pas de
condamner ici en bloc la notion même de
crédit d'impôt ni de profiter de ce
débat pour revenir à un antagonisme
désormais classique celui qui oppose les
partisans d'une politique de l'offre au
partisans d'une politique de la demande
il s'agit dans le contexte de tension
budgétaire et dans la situation de crise
globale que nous connaissons de
déterminer les formes d'action les plus
efficaces et les plus efficientes qui
s'offrent à nous et lorsque cela est
nécessaire de détecter et de corriger
les éventuelles erreurs d'appréciation
que nous avons pu commettre avec
l'expérience du CCE qui est la nôtre
aujourd'hui je crois que deux erreurs de
conception peuvent désormais être
confirmées la première erreur c'est
d'avoir mal estimé les effets
éventuellement contreproductifs de C
certaines mesures prises au cours des
deux dernières années et de la
complexité de la mise en place du cice
lui-même le rapport du comité de suivi
indique ainsi clairement que ce dernier
dont on sait qu'il est encore en phase
de montée en charge est nettement moins
utilisé cette année par les entreprises
que ce que le gouvernement prévoyait 13
milliards d'euros de versement était
initialement attendu en 2014 au titre du
Cece de l'année 2013 la prévision
révisée retenue pour le plan pour le PLF
n'est finalement que de 10,8 milliards
d'euros même si l'on peut trouver ici
quelques motifs de satisfaction après
tout cela représente moins de dépenses
pour l'État il est difficile de ne pas
s'interroger sur ce constat ne serait-ce
pas là au moins partiellement le
résultat du mode de financement du cice
lui-même ainsi que d'autres mesures
prises depuis et dont l'effet récessif a
déjà été largement évoqué je pense par
exemple à la hausse de la TVA intervenu
sur des secteurs tels que les transport
en commun la rénovation des bâtiments et
la culture ne faudrait-il pas remettre
ENF tout ceci à plat et évaluer
clairement les effets croisés de toutes
ces politiques car il est en l'état bien
difficile d'en percevoir les effets
positifs alors que les effets les plus
négatifs sont beaucoup plus visibles il
est d'ailleurs intéressant de relever
que s'agissant de la hausse de la TVA et
notamment la hausse de 19,6 à 20 % son
absence de R cussion sur les prix finaux
pratiqués par certains secteurs dont
tmoine d'ailleurs la très faible
inflation que nous observons depuis le
début de l'année et bien cette absence
de répercussion masque un effet pervers
qui contribue lui aussi à diminuer les
effets promis du cice pour les
entreprises cela peut notamment se
traduire par une rétractation des marche
non pas tellement des distributeurs
eux-mêmes mais de leurs fournisseurs les
producteurs parmi lesquels beaucoup de
PME qui auraient pourtant bien besoin de
surplu d'oxygène et de marge pour
investir et embaucher la deuxième erreur
qui découle en partie de la première
c'est justement le flou qui entoure le
cice quant à sa finalité en matière de
création d'emploi j'en veux pour preuve
l'évolution du discours du gouvernement
lui-même sur la question le cice devait
d'abord permettre nous disitons au
moment de ce lancement de créer 300000
emplois à terme on a ensuite équ un
ordre de grandeur plus proche des 150000
emplois et récemment le ministre des
Finances est même allé jusqu'à laisser
clairement entendre qu'il n'y avait pas
de lien direct entre cice et emploi en
outre parce que le bénéfice du cice est
limité au salaire dépassant pas
l'équivalent de deux fois et demi le
SMIC par an il ne facilite en rien
l'embauche dans les secteurs les plus
qualifiés alors que ceci aurait bien
besoin d'être dynamisé pour renforcer la
France sur la scène internationale et
relancer son é économie de sorte qu'au
final le rapport annuel du comité de
suivi reste très prudent quant au
résultats du dispositif sur les
créations d'emploi il indique bien en
reprenant l'enquête de conjoncture de
ninc paru en juillet dernier que je cite
48 % des entreprises de service et 34 %
des entreprises de l'industrie disent
qu'il y aura un impact sur leur EMB
qu'il aura un impact sur leur embauche
mais il s'agit là de données
déclaratives et pour le coup des plus
imprécises de manre manière plus
générale forcé de constater que nous
manquons de visibilité quant à
l'utilisation réelle qui est faite de
leur cice par les entreprises qui ont
recours alors madame la présidente
madame la ministre mes chers collègues
le groupe écologiste disons-le est
favorable à des mesures qui viendraient
soutenir non pas l'ensemble des acteurs
économiques quel que soit leur poids ou
quel que soit leur modèle ou leur santé
réelle mais à des mesures de soutien
sectoriel qui donneraient à l'état un
véritable rôle de stratège l'état
stratège et permettrait de soutenir nos
entreprises les plus concernées par la
concurrence internationale nos
entreprises véritablement innovante et
surtout les acteurs de la transition
écologique et les acteurs d'une
transition technologique que nous
appelons tous de nos vœux Michel SAA
indiquait récemment que les cice étaient
là pour permettre aux entreprises de
retrouver leur marche et donc d'investir
ou d'embaucher ou de former en tout cas
de préparer l'avenir et il est vra vrai
qu'un crédit d'impôt peut effectivement
être fort utile dans cette perspective
et qu'il y a des entreprises et des
industries qui ne demandent qu'à se
développer et à embaucher mais nous ne
pourrons pas les y aider avec des outils
aussi généraux imparfaitement et
précipitamment conçu de teles
dépensent trop d'argent public sans
permettre de financer assez de telles
entreprises et qu'on ne vienne pas nous
opposer l'Europe ses directives et ses
règlements qui au dire de certains nous
empêcheraient de mettre en place
pareilles démarches c'est tout
simplement faux elle laisse en réalité
de véritables marges de manœuvre en la
matière sans sans compter que c'est
aussi à nous de nous emparer des
politiques européennes pour mieux les
orienter avec nos partenaires alors que
les institutions européennes terminent
justement leur renouvellement les
difficultés du CCE comme cell plus
général de notre économie et de l'Europe
tout entière nous démontrre que c'est
d'une utilisation précise articulée et
stratégique des moyens publics dont nous
avons besoin aujourd'hui à nous donc de
bien en tirer les conséquences je vous
remercie merci chers collègues la parole
est à Madame Laurence Cohen du groupe
CRC madame la présidente madame la
ministre mes chers collègues comme l'ont
souligné plusieurs orateurs le cice a
été institué par l'article 66 de la loi
de finance rectificative pour 2012 et
est entré en vigueur officielle le 1er
janvier 2013 il fait partie du PACT de
responsabilité du gouvernement très
largement inspiré par le rapport Gallois
pour rappel notre Haute Assemblée avait
rejeté cette proposition mais du fait de
la navette parlementaire elle a été
réintroduite à l'Assemblée nationale le
cice existe donc à présent depuis 21
mois durée insuffisante pour juger de la
pleine efficacité du dispositif mais
assez longue pour avoir un premier
retour d'expérience un constat s'impose
celui des incertitudes même du cice en
ce qui concerne son efficacité
économique et sociale c'est-à-dire en
terme d'activité de croissance et
d'emploi et quand 17 millions et demi
d'euros sont en jeu en 2015 il nous
apparaît essentiel que les
parlementaires que nous sommes puissions
autant d'ailleurs que les citoyens et
les citoyennes avoir des informations
claires sur les réalités d'un tel
dispositif
pour financer le cice on a augmenté la
TVA on a augmenté le rendement de
l'impôt sur le revenu on va accroître la
fiscalité dite écologique et on a réduit
et on réduit encore les dépenses
publiques le cice apparaît de plus en
plus comme un chèque en blanc accordé
aux entreprises sans contrepartie
visible sinon nous n'aurions pas la
situation de l'emploi que que nous
connaissons le CCE prétend muscler
l'offre alors que celle-ci souffre
notamment d'une insuffisance de demande
et pour cause face à un pouvoir d'achat
en berne dont la première conséquence
est la baisse de la consommation des
ménages ce dispositif est en quelque
sorte la quintessence d'une politique
assumée largesse et laxisme pour
certains et rigueur austérité imposé
pour le plus grand nombre comment ne pas
s'interroger sur l'essence même de ces
milliards d'euros accordés depuis des
années aux entreprises dont le cice
n'est qu'une forme parmi d'autres une de
plus avec les exonérations de cotisation
sociale les niches fiscales le régime
des groupes la niche Copé la suppression
de la taxe professionnelle et j'en passe
c'est en quelque sorte ce la serise sur
le gâteau déjà bien garnie si je puis
m'exprimer ainsi avant la baisse
programmée du taux de l'impôt sur les
sociétés du fait de ce que vous appelez
le coût du travail et qui en fait prend
en compte les salaires sur toutes leurs
forme et bien c'est le postulat que l'on
fait depuis longtemps sur le fait que
les entreprises ne seraient pas
compétitive le rapport de la mission
d'information mené par notre collègue
Michel de Messine démontre que les
allègements de cotisation social et
d'impôts nont pas suffit à enrayer le
chômage bien au contraire et j'y
reviendrai notamment avec les chiffres
issus de mon département tout aussi
grave cette politique d'exonération de
cotisation sociale met à mal depuis des
années le financement de la la
protection sociale financé à 80 % par
des cotisations notre protection sociale
ne l'est plus aujourd'hui qu' environ 60
%. d'ailleurs notons ensemble mes chers
collègues que plus la sécurité sociale
est fiscalisée plus elle est en déficit
les exonérations de cotisation non
ciblées ne vont pas aux entreprises qui
en ont le plus besoin ni aux secteurs
les plus exposés à la concurrence bien
au contraire elle favorise les
entreprises du CAC40 et ce sont de
véritables primes au bas salairire et
aux secteurs les plus abrités en
conséquence devons-nous continuer dans
cette voie madame la ministre je reviens
à présence spécifique au cice et aux
premières évaluations que le comité de
suivi a pu faire après une année et demi
de mise en œuvre le rapport du comité de
suivi est très évasif pour ne pas dire
plus sur les effets de cette mesure
néanmoins j'aimerais ici vous livrer
quelques chiffres qui viennent compléter
ceux de ma collègue Marie-France
Beaufils ce sont des exemples locaux et
concrets qui interrogent les
parlementaires communistes que nous
sommes mais je pense bien au-delà tous
les parlementaires sur ces bancs le
groupe mulz bien connu dans le Nord
perçoit depuis 2 ans S 27 millions
d'euros ce même groupe va supprimer 300
postes en 3 ans d'après les chiffres que
m'a communiqué mon collègue Dominique
vatrin
61,4 million d'euros auraient été
distribué à 6000 entreprises du pas
decalais et pour combien d'emplois créé
combien d'emplois sauvés Peugeot Citroën
va liquider 8000 emplois en fermant
l'usine d'olenet et en réduisant la
production à Renn avec le CCE le
gouvernement récompense en quelque sorte
PSA de plus de 100 millions d'euros pour
cette police politique la Poste va
récupérer quant à elle 270 millions
d'euros et entend supprimer encore des
milliers d'emplois d'ici l'an prochain
par ailleurs total dont on vient
d'apprendre la disparation tragique du
PDG va toucher 80 millions d'euros alors
que ce groupe
pétrolier organise volontairement le déf
son déficit en France je poursuis avec
un dernier exemple issu de mon
département Ricot qui appartient à un
groupe mondial déclare avoir obtenu une
aide publique d'un d'euros au titre du
cice pour l'année 2013 tout en faisant
part de son intention de supprimer 328
emplois en France dont 200 sur son site
de
ringis ainsi dans le Val de Marne ce
sont 65 millions d'euros qui ont été
distribués à 9817 entreprises de ce
territoire et pourtant comme partout le
chômage n'a pas baissé et faut-il le
rappeler ici il a augmenté au plan
national de 7,9 % en 2013 on ne peut pas
vraiment parler d'effets bénéfiques même
minime de du cice madame la ministre je
crains que ces exemples ne soient pas
isolés est-ce à dire que les aides
publiques financent les licenciements et
parfois des délocalisations quelle
mesure entendez-vous prendre pour ce
type d'entreprise ne puisse obtenir une
nouvelle mesure de crédit d'impôt au
titre du cice pour l'année 2015 si des
licenciements sont avérés par ailleurs
comment ne pas s'interroger sur le fait
que 16 des plus grandes entreprises
françaises faisant partie du 40 cumule
une réduction d'impôts de 823 millions
d'euros en 2013 et qui devrait atteindre
1,24 millions d'euros en 2014 là aussi
leur politique en matière d'emploi nous
laisse plus que dubitative Air France
ous Sanofi pour ne citer que deux autres
exemples ne Brill ne brillent guerre par
leur création d'emploi mais au contraire
hélas par leurs plans sociaux chers
collègues quelle collectivité
aujourd'hui accorde des subventions des
avantages sans aucun engagement retour
outre mon mandat de sénatrice je suis
conseillère régionale Île-de-France
cette région comme beaucoup d'autres
n'accorde pas de crédit aux entreprises
qui ne mènne pas une politique vertueuse
en terme d'emploi d'égalité
professionnelle notamment l'argent
public ne peut-être distribué sans un
minimum de contrôle et n'est-ce pas le
rôle des parlementaires que nous hmes
que nous sommes de nous en assurer
d'autant que les efforts demandés
reposent toujours sur les mêmes nos
concitoyens et les
collectivités nous sommes vous l'avez
remarqué plus que critique au groupe CRC
sur ce dispositif mais nous voulons une
fois de plus être constructif dans
l'intérêt de nos concitoyens dans cet
esprit complétant les propos de notre
collègue Marie-France Beaufils voici
deux propositions supplémentaires qui je
l'espère trouveront de l'écho près de
vous madame la ministre la première est
de créer un indice du coût du capital
pour inciter véritablement au
réinvestissement des dividendes dans
l'entreprise la seconde est de créer
rapidement un observatoire national avec
des déclinaisons départementales sur
l'utilisation du cice afin d'évaluer de
façon objective sa pertinence et d'en
tirer ensuite les conclusions qui
s'imposeront c'est notamment la demande
que nous avons formulé Christian Favier
et moi-même auprès du Préfet du
valdeemes mes chers collègues je crois
vraiment que ce débat est essentiel
aujourd'hui à quelques jours de l'examen
du PLFSS et du PLF il est utile de
rappeler que le montant du cice
correspond peu ou au montant entretenu
pour ne pas dire fabriquer du déficit de
la Sécurité sociale ti tironsen ensemble
les conclusions qui s'imposent je vous
remercie de votre
attention merci Madame Cohen la parole
est à notre collègue Pierre Colomba du
groupe RDSE vous avez la
parole
madame la présidente madame la ministre
chers collègues vous savez le crédit
d'impôt le crédit d'impôt compétitivité
emploi devait être une sorte de couteau
suisse de Laur relance économique
française par l'amélioration de l'offre
un outil
multifonction le cice dit la publicité a
pour objectif de redonner aux
entreprises des marges de manœuvre pour
investir prospecter de nouveaux marchés
innover faciliter la recherche et
l'innovation recruter restaurer leurs
fonds de roulement ou accompagner la
transition écologique et énergétique
grâce à une baisse du du coût du travail
stimulation de l'investissement et de la
compétitivité dans les secteurs porteurs
d'avenir développement de
l'emploi difficile de dire mieux après
les intentions forcément excellentes
voyons la réalité en tout cas les
enseignements de la première année
complète de mise en œuvre du cice
2013 premier constat le rapport du
comité de suivi du cice publié en
septembre
2014 dont l'importance du contenu
informatif est inversement proportionnel
à la longueur 115 page avec les annexes
nous estun maigre secours
essentiellement rédigé au conditionnel
pauvre en donné factuelle précise il se
contente d'une évaluation de l'emploi du
cice évolution du taux de Mar des
entreprises de l'investissement de
l'emploi une estimation donc à partir
des seules intentions exprimées par les
entreprises lesquelles d'ailleurs ne
vont pas dire autre chose que ce qu'on
attend d'elles leur intention ne peut
qu'être d'utiliser le cice d'abord pour
l'investissement ensuite pour l'emploi
le rapport n'en note pas moins cependant
que l'impact du CCE sur les prix
pourtant élément essentiel de la
compétitivité s'observe
rarement à regarder les choses de plus
près la réalité telle qu'elle ressort de
l'examen de cet exercice 2013 est
sensiblement différente s'agissant en
tout cas des grandes entreprises du 440
elles aussi élégibles au cice de façon
massive on vient de le dire puisqu'en
2013 elles ont augmenté le versement de
leurs dividendes et réduit leurs
investissements autour de 40 milliards
de dividendes versées soit 5,5 % plaçant
ainsi la France dans le peloton de tête
européen pour cette discipline
internationale leur taux de distribution
médian c'est-à-dire la part du bénéfice
allant aux dividendes atteint 48 %
contre 46 % en 2012 en clair la moitié
des bénéfices dégagés revient aux
actionnaires dans le même temps les
investissements des entreprises non
financières du C40 ont reculé de 5 % en
2013 dégradation qui d'ailleurs s'est
poursuivi à peu près au même rythme au
1er trimestre
2014 on est donc loin du fameux théorème
d'Elm d'elmou schmitth que les bénéfices
d'aujourd'hui sont les investissements
de demain et les emplois d'après-demain
au point même que François Hollande
lui-même a cru bon de rappeler en août
2014 au patron leur devoir d'utiliser je
cite pleinement les moyens du cice pour
investir et embaucher et non distribuer
des dividendes
on ne doute pas qu'ils seront sensibles
à un conseil aussi paternellement
délivré côté intéressé on nous explique
benoitement que je cite les entreprises
font de l'investissement lorsqu'elles
ont des projets de croissance rentable
pas simplement parce qu'elles ont des
cashfow abondants la décision d'investir
dépend avant tout des perspectives
futures or elles ne sont pas trop
optimiste pour l'heure en Europe cette
analyse c'est celle de Fabrice tevenau
analyse à la analyste pardon à la
Société Générale interrogé par les échos
le journal de Monsieur Bernard Arnaud
première fortune française selon Forbes
donc une référence une référence qui dit
clairement qu'en l'absence de demande
une politique de l'offre et voué à
l'échec un entrepreneur n'investit et
n'embauche que s'il a l'espoir de vendre
quels que soi les cadeaux fiscaux dont
il pourra bénéficier conclusion qui
d'ailleurs bien qu'exprimé dans le
langage en gourque de rigueur ressort
aussi du rapport du comité de suivi du
cice je le cite si c'est pas vraiment en
français vous me le pardonnerez c'est
pas moi qui l'ai écrit ces résultats
bien que partiels confirment ceux des
précédentes vagues d'enquête
l'affectation du CCE en 2014 semble
fortement dépendante de la situation
conjoncturelle de l'entreprise de ses
contraintes et de ses perspectives
l'utilisation du cice semble venir
conforter des décisions qui répondent
prioritairement à la dynamique
conjoncturelle des entreprises en un mot
et en clair la réussite de la politique
de l'offre est suspendue à l'apparition
d'une demande comment précisément la
faire apparaître voilà toute la question
voilà la vraie question en changeant
l'angle de de vision en considérant ce
qui se passe au niveau d'une entreprise
particulière la cohérence de la
politique économique du gouvernement
apparaît-elle mieux parmi les entreprise
publique largement bénéficiaire du cice
l'exemple de la
poste qui aura reçu en 2013 de l'ordre
de 300 millions d'euros de CIC et
357 millions d'euros en 2014 cet exemple
m'ont fait douter certes on peut se
féliciter que cet argent est permis à la
poste de réaliser 627 millions de
bénéfices en 2013 en ha hase de 31 %
malgré une chute de 30 % de son résultat
d'exploitation mais si le but du cice
est d'améliorer notre balance extérieure
on devrait pouvoir se trouver d'autres
entreprises plus exposées à la
concurrence même constat s'agissant de
la politique de l'emploi la Poste
poursuivant la réduction de ces
effectifs comme cela a été dit tout à
l'heure 4500 emplois supprimés en 2013
après 2500 en 2012 le processus est
engagé depuis longtemps entendons-nous
bien je critique absolument pas l'aide
publique à la poste qui remplit des
missions de service public que personne
d'autre n'assume notamment par sa
présence sur l'ensemble du territoire
national j'ai simplement un peu de mal à
saisir la cohérence de la politique du
gouvernement envers elle en 2013 donc la
Poste reçoit 300 millions d'euros d'te
publique par le biais du CSE mais en
même temps elle est ponctionnée de 171
millions d'euros de dividendees 23
millions d'euros de plus qu'en 2012 tout
en continuant d'ailleurs à assumer la
charge des réductions tarifaires
accordées à la presse soit de l'ordre de
500 millions d'euros comprennent qui
pourra en matière de cohérence et de
clarification on devrait donc pouvoir
faire mieux de même qu'en matière de
politique fiscale autre versant de notre
affaire qui son nom a été évoqué tout à
l'heure si l'on en croit Thomas
picketti le ce cice se contente
d'ajouter des couches de complexité sur
un système qui en compte déjà beaucoup
trop Thomas picketti auquel
j'emprunterai ma conclusion puisqu'il me
faut conclure le rouge est mis si le
gouvernement ne fait rien alors le
crédit d'impôt compétitivité emploi
d'iciice restera comme le symbole de
l'échec de ce quinquena à moins que ce
ne soit la réforme territoriale ça c'est
moi qui
l'ajoute merci chers
collègu la parole est à Monsieur Marcel
Bourquin du groupe socialiste j'ai dit
martial oui non non j'ai dis martial je
vais articuler mieux la prochaine fois
non
non madame la présidente madame la
ministre mes chers collègues nous sommes
invités
à à cette session
pour aborder la question du cice et à
l'invitation du groupe
CRC 14 mois à peine bien sûr on
dispose
de d'éléments d'évaluation on dispose de
rapports parlementaires et des enquêtes
de
conjoncture je pense que pour juger une
politique publique il nous faut plus de
14 mois pour juger de la pertinence d'un
dispositif ces informations sont encore
très parcellaaires puisque nous sommes
en pleine montée en charge du
dispositif et pourtant ce débat est
important et et si vous le voulez bien
après l'intervention de mon ami
jean-germain j'intervrai plutôt sur la
question économique et
industrielle tout d'abord il faut
rappeler le double objectif du cice
premier objectif accompagner l'ensemble
du tissu économique vers une montée en
gamme nécessaire à sa compétitivité
combiné à un allègement de
charge
deuxè stratégie c priorité au PME TPE et
surtout dans
l'industrie sommes dans une économie
ouverte et quand on est dans une
économie ouverte la compétitivité des
entreprises ne peut pas être ignoré en
l'ignorant inévitablement on la
condamneraitames entreprises il y a un
premier bilan positif sur les PME TP en
ce qui concerne l'investissement 704000
entreprises sont bénéficiair du
dispositif j'ai 400 entreprises sur le
terrain de ma commune je peux vous dire
qu'ils ont
apprécié cet allègement et comment cette
possibilité pour eux nouvelle il l'ont
concrétisé en ayant un peu plus de marge
de manœuvre ou dans des
investissements
le le comment la créance fiscale de
septembre 2014 se monte à 8 7 milliards
elle s'approche des 18,8 milliards
prévus cette année 18 milliards l'année
prochaine écoutez le cice en vitesse de
croisière peut réduire l'écart constaté
entre l'Allemagne et la France de 50 %.
nous parlons d'un point de PIB soit 20
milliards d'euros ça ce n'est pas rien
et cet écart de compétitivité dont on
parle depuis des années dans cet
hémicycle il y a une volonté de s'y
attaquer et de faire en sorte qu'il soit
diminué concernant la destination du
cice comme ça a été dit tout à l'heure
des grands groupes pvoyurs d'emploi sont
présents pour émerger sur ce cice mais
nous savons aussi que des PME nombreuses
bénéficient de celui-ci et il faut s'en
réjouir pleinement nous n'avons pas
d'évaluation plus précise mais je pense
que madame la ministre vous donnerez
vous nous donnerez des renseignements
sur ce sujet mais nous en aurons surtout
dans les années à venir concernant la
conservation et la création
d'emploi mais je pense qu'il est
vraiment très tôt aujourd'hui pour avoir
ces évaluations je suis je suis par
contre vraiment très satisfait
d'apprendre que plus de la moitié des
entreprises qui ont bénéficié du cice
prévoi de le consacrer à
l'investissement et c'est là que se
situe le grand défi de l'économie
française notamment de son industrie il
faut drainer ce cice vers
l'investissement et dans l'industrie je
dis satisfait parce que on doit aller
beaucoup plus loin 19
% des entreprises du secteur industriel
ont
bénéficié de ce crédit d'impôt nous
avons je crois le devoir d'augmenter ce
taux l'année prochaine pourquoi mais
parce
que quand on constate l'écart
différentiel entre la France et
l'Allemagne au niveau charge il faut
regarder aussi au niveau investissement
industriel et par
exemple quand vous regardez la
robotisation de nos
entreprise notre appareil productif a
quatre fois moins de robots qu'en
Allemagne deux fois moins qu'en
Italie et ce crédit impôt emploi
compétitivité doit servir justement à
combler cet écart et si nous arrivons à
combler cet écart nous aurons une
compétitivité capable capable justement
de se comparer avec d'autres pays
européens et au niveau mondial je crois
que un meilleur ciblage est
possible je sais que Bery n'est pas
fermé à cette perspective mais pour cela
il faut un effort majeur de traçabilité
des créances dans les documents
comptables avec l'aide des professions
du chiffre
de manière à ce que les partenaires
sociaux puissent aussi s'en saisir mais
aussi que nous les élus nous ayons
l'ensemble des
informations la question qui est posée
c'est la montée en gamme de nos
entreprises des produits de nos
entreprises et cela doit être débattu
dans l'ensemble des conseils
d'administration C doit être débattu par
le Parlement mais pour ça madame la
ministre les gardesfous prévus par la
loi doivent être aussi
effectifs effectivement ici et là on
constate des entreprises qui peuvent
profiter de ce crédit d'impôt pour
délocaliser pour comment supprimer des
emplois et investir ailleurs et là sur
des questions comme celle-là nous devons
avoir un contrôle très effectif le cice
n'est pas le seul levier économique euh
bien sûr il y a toutes les
interrogations et les remarques qui ont
été faites ici dans dans l'hémicycle
mais le le rapport Gallois c'est 35
mesures pour la
compétitivité et dans ces 35 mesures
pour la compétitivité il y a par exemple
les délais de
paiement 13 milliards par
an les sous-traitants des grands groupes
ont 13 milliards de retard de délai de
paiement par an et ces délais de
paiement s'aggrave et lorsque nous
abordons le cice nous devons aborder les
questions de
la question des des écosystèmes
productifs de la simplification
administrative et tous ces éléments mis
les uns avec les autres contribuent à
renforcer l'attractivité de notre
secteur
industriel
pas un dispositif parmi les autres qu'il
faut aborder mais c'est l'ensemble des
dispositifs je crois que chers collègues
nous ne pouvons pas rester avec 5
millions de demandeurs
d'emploi nous devons nous attaquer à la
question de notre système productif
depuis 30 ans nous regardons notre
France
désindustrialisée il fautavoir avoir
cette volonté de redresser euh la
l'économie de la France et notream notre
industrie et on ne peut plus assister
comme ça les bras ballants en disant les
mêmes choses toujours mais en faisant en
sorte que nous posions les vrais
problèmes et que nous apportions de
vraies solutions voilà chers collègues
ce que je voulais vous dire sur ces
questions mais je finirai en disant à au
lecteurs assidu de picketti il y a deux
questions qu'il a abordé et qui n'ont
pas été abordé aujourd'hui faut-il mais
je sais faut-il aborder continuer à
mener des politiques déflationnistes
quand nous sommes près de la déflation
puis deuxième chose pourquoi les
actionnaires ont des revenus plus
importants que la croissance ces deux
questions que pose Thomas picketti
mériteraiit un vrai débat dans cette
assemblée
merci mon cher
collègue la parole est à Monsieur
Yannick vugrenard du groupe
socialiste madame la présidente madame
la ministre mes chers collègues le
Crédit Impôt compétitivité emploi
constituait donc l'une des C décisions
concrètes du Pacte pour la croissance la
compétitivité et l'emploi annoncé à la
suite du rapport de luoui Galois sur la
compétitivité de l'industrie française
son objectif améliorer la compétitivité
de nos entreprises en particulier à
travers des efforts en matière de
recrutement d'investissement de
recherche ou encore d'innovation ça a
été dit avant moi alors que les premiers
versements de ce crédit d'impôt
parviennent aux entreprises depuis
quelques mois il nous appartient de
réaliser bien sûr ce que nous faisons
aujourd'hui un point d'étape sur cette
mesure centrale dans la politique de
relance économique de notre gouvernement
examinons les chiffres dont nous
disposons aujourd'hui et qui nous
viennent notamment du comité de suivi du
cice dans son rapport du 30 septembre
dernier à ce jour 8 milillards 700
millions d'euros ont été déclarés et 5
milillards 200 ont d'ors et déjà été
restitués ce sont quand même 713000
entreprises sur le million concerné qui
ont ainsi de demander à bénéficier de ce
dispositif 11 % sont des
micro-entreprises 31 % des PME et 25 %
des entrepris de taille intermédiaire
certes le gouvernement avait escompté
que les entreprises déclarent 10
milillards 800 millions mais le temps
n'est pas à tirer un bilan définitif
bien sûr aujourd'hui du cice car il est
trop tôt pour voir ses effets sur le
comportement des entreprises et cela
pour plusieurs raisons premièrement au
moment de l'enquête réalisée par le
comité de suivi un/art des entreprises
n'avaient pas encore arrêté leur compte
le montant de 8 milliards 7 ne concerne
en effet que Cell ayant cl leur exercice
entre janvier et avril de cette année
2014 deuxièmement la créance ultime au
titre de 2013 ne sera connu qu'en 2017
c'est-à-dire à échéance du droit au
crédit d'impôt puisque les entreprises
disposent de 3 ans pour l'utiliser
troisièmement pour mesurer la réelle
efficacité du cice sur notre économie il
faut attendre les fruits de la baisse
des cotisations qui ne seront mesurables
que dans de ou 3 ans minimum ça montée
en puissance est donc par nature
progressive et nous pouvons aisément
mesurer le décalage normal entre les
annonces et les tous premiers effets
mais nous savons mes chers collèg depuis
quelques temps déjà que le temps
économique n'a rien à voir avec le temps
politique et encore moins avec le temps
médiatique cependant il est possible de
tirer quelques enseignements du rapport
du comité de suivi ainsi que d'une
enquête qui a été réalis par l'INC
auprès de 5000 entreprises sur la
manière dont elle compte utiliser ce
cicece tout d'abord cette enquête nous
apprend que la connaissance du
dispositif progresse de manière notable
chez les dirigeants par rapport à son
lancement en 2013 interroger sur leur
future utilisation 34 % des entreprises
du secteur de l'industrie estim que le
cice leur permettra d'embaucher et ce
chiffre grimpe à 48 % dans le secteur
des services par ailleurs 5 % des
entreprises du secteur de l'industrie et
52 % du secteur des services indique
destiné le cice à de l'investissement
son rôle premier semblerait donc rempli
ce qui démontre que dans les services
comme dans l'industrie il répond à un
besoin compte tenu de ces éléments toute
analyse sur le cice et ses effets n
nécessite pardon prudence et humilité le
retour sur l'année écoulée est
extrêmement instructif sur la façon dont
sa mécanique a été progressivement
assimilée et sur les obstacles que cette
assimilation a pu logiquement rencontrer
mais cette année ne peut être considérée
comme véritablement représentative
réellement des comportements à venir
lorsque les acteurs se seront approprié
le dispositif et que sa stabilis sa
stabilité sera considérée comme acquise
certaines adaptations devront être
envisagé d'autres méritent sûrement de
ne pas attendre je souhaiterais revenir
sur quelques points qui ont créé la
polémique à savoir l'utilisation du cice
par certains grands groupes pour
augmenter les dividends il est évident
qu'il ne doit pas être détourné de son
objet initial à savoir la sauvegarde et
la création d'emploi ainsi que la
modernisation de notre appareil
productif c'est pourquoi je soutiens
tout ce qui vise à demander aux
entreprises de rembourser les aides
versées dès lors que celle-ci servent à
augmenter les dividendes ou la
rémunération des actionnaires ou qu'elle
accompagne la fermeture d'entreprise ou
de suc succursal rentable j'ai le cas
sur mon département comme Martial
Bourquin l'a rappelé tout à l'heure pour
le sien la cita qui a bénéficié du cice
et qui a fermé l'entreprise et qui a
délocalisé en Pologne il est bien
évidemment choquant que les dividendes
versées en France ai progressé de 30,3 %
par rapport au 2è trimestre 2013 pour
atteindre près de 41 milliards d'euros
notre pays aujourd'hui est le leader
européen dans dans ce domaine vu l'état
de morosité de notre économie mes chers
collègues je ne peux comprendre ceux qui
se sont élevés pour ceux qui ne sont pas
élevés pour souligner cette
contradiction mais le principe même du
cice n'est pas à mettre en cause du fait
du comportement déplacé de certaines
grandes entreprises condamnables pour
autant encore faut-il avoir des
dispositifs pour contrôler des
dispositifs pour sanctionner si
nécessaire rappelons que les 3/4 du
cicece bénéficient aujourd'hui dans la
réalité à des PME ou des entreprises de
taille intermédiaire a priori donc nos
côtés en bourse globalement il a donc
plus servi à reconstituer objectivement
la trésorerie des PME redressant leur
Marg et se descendétant plutôt qu'à
gonfler les dividendes des grands
groupes le pacte pour la croissance la
compétitivité et l'emploi dont fait
partie le CCE a donc été conçu pour
préparer l'avenir de notre pays c'est
une impérieuse nécessité cela ne sera
pas un jour nous pouvons comprendre que
cela prenne du temps par contre et ceci
est vrai madame la ministre pour le cice
comme pour toute forme d'aide aux
entreprises en général la
conditionnalité selon moi est un
impératif si nous voulons inscrire dans
un rapport si nous voulons nous inscrire
dans un rapport gagnant- gagnant sur le
plan économique mais aussi sur
l'indispensable pédagogie politique à
mettre en œuvre nous aurions
collectivement tout à gagner si chaque
chef chef d'entreprise indiquait aux
salariés très simplement ce qui a été
fait avec l'argent du cice cette
nécessaire transparence serait une
simple initiative de bon sens où les
salariés citoyens seraient en toute
logique informés de l'utilisation par
leur entreprise des donniers publiques
donc de l'effort collectif il est aussi
important madame la ministre d'affiner
le dispositif afin que ce soit
véritablement les secteurs économiques
qui en ont le plus besoin qui on bénéf
ici notamment l'industrie avec un effort
de transparence profitable à tous
évitant ainsi les dérives constatées au
bout du compte et j'en termine si le
cice peut incontestablement aider à
renforcer la compétitivité de nos
entreprises il ne peut et ne doit pas se
faire sans transparence sans nécessaire
contrôle et sans information des
salariés concernés tout ceci serait j'en
suis persuadé mes chers collègues le
gage d'une plus grande efficacité merci
de votre attention merci chers collègues
la parole est maintenant à madame Carole
Delga secrétaire d'État chargée du
commerce de l'artisanat de la
consommation et de l'économie sociale et
solidaire vous avez la parole Madame le
Ministre madame la Présidente Mesdames
et Messieurs les sénatrices et les
sénateurs je souhaite en
effet porter mon propos dans un contexte
plus général dans lequel nous avons
souhaité inscrire la politique du Crédit
Impôt compétitivité emploi mais
également dans les perspectives que nous
avons pour le soutien aux
entreprise il est clair que comme le
rappelait Michel croier on ne change pas
la société par décret mais il est
nécessaire que dans le temps législatif
et aussi que dans le temps règlementière
nous soyons attentifs aux évolutions que
nous devons impulser par rapport à la
compétitivité des entreprises rappelez
qu'en 2012 nous avons hérité d'une
situation très complexe avec une
industrie qui était très abîmée mais
également avec une compétitivité perdu
pour beaucoup de nos entreprises nous
avons donc souhaité qu'il y ait en effet
une politiqu qui permettent à nos
entreprises de retrouver des marges pour
pouvoir retrouver une compétitivité
forte et une capacité à soutenir notre
tissu industriel mais une capacité
également à recréer de l'emploi puisque
il y a aussi et vous le savez cette
problématique forte d'un taux de chômage
très élevé dans notre pays nous
avons bien sûr malheureusement cela ne
s'arrange pas mais nous avons des
politiques qui sont coordonnés pour
promouvoir l'emploi mais pour également
reconstituer les services publics qui
avaient été laminé tel que l'éducation
nationale ou tel que la
justice
je vous propose d'informer directement
monsieur payon si vous voulez bien
monsieur le sénateur je vous rappellerai
donc la philosophie du crédit d'impôt
compétitivité emploi cette philosophie
c'est bien sûr de recréer un cercle
vertueux à travers bien sûr
l'investissement à travers l'innovation
mais également à travers la
compétitivité pour l'emploi le crédit
d'impôt compétitivité emploi est un des
piliers de la stratégie économique du
gouvernement et rappelant cette
stratégie qui repose sur trois piliers
tout d'abord réduire le déficit public
et assaignir nos comptes publ rappelez
que sous le quinquena donc précédent il
y a sous donc avec le la présidence de
Nicolas Sarkozi nous avions une
progression de la dette annuelle de 5 %
depuis 2012 nous n'ons réduit bien sûr
cette progression qui n'est plus que de
3 %. nous avons aussi souhaité parce que
bien sûr il faut être responsable quand
nous sommes au gouvernement c'est un
ralentissement
important de la dépense publique mais un
ralentissement de la dépense publique
qui soit compatible avec une un soutien
à cette économie nous avons en effet sur
3 ans prévu une réduction de la dépense
publique de 50 milliards alors que
d'autres nous proposent 100 milliards je
ne sais pas où on pourrait arriver à
faire de telles économies sans casser le
modèle républicain l'effort de réduction
de la dépense publique est un effort
sans précédent mais qui est adapté à
notre situation économique et en effet
cet effort est demandé bien sûr au
ministère bien sûr aux collectivités
locales mais je me rappelle il me semble
qu'avec la réforme de la taxe
professionnelle nous avons privé les
collectivité locale d'un impôt dynamique
et qui par la même occasion a fait en
sorte que les carnets de commande des
entreprises du bâtiment et des travaux
publics ont commencé à trouver certaines
problématiques nous avions également
bien sûr demander un effort au réseau
consulaire la France doit être redressée
elle demande la mobilisation de toute et
de tous voilà pour ce débat qui s'est
tenu mardi après-midi au Sénat un débat
portant sur le cice les crédits impôt
compétitivité emploi un débat qui se
tenait à la demande du groupe communiste
je vous rappelle que le cice et bien est
une mesure un dispositif qui a été mise
en place au mois de janvier 2013 après
les préconisations du rapport de Louis
Galois rapport portant sur la
compétitivité des entreprises qui
estimaient que le coût du travail est
trop élevé en France alors certes le
cice tarde à porter ses fruits pour
l'instant mais vous avez pu l'entendre
la secrétaire d'État Carole Delga est
intervenue en conclusion en citant
Michel croser pour dire qu'on ne change
pas la société par décret mais qu'il
faut pouvoir impulser les évolutions et
les suivre en clair si le C ce n'a pas
encore porté ses fruits et bien il faut
encore accompagner ce dispositif pour
qu'il puisse porter ses fruits et enfin
alimenter la croissance française vous
pouvez toujours voir et revoir toutes
les séances sur notre site
publsena.fr très bonne fin de journée
sur les chaînes
parlementaires